schönen dank für die gelegenheit hier zu
sein ich freue mich dass ich das erste
mal als bundeskanzler in der türkei sein
kann und ich bin sehr dankbar dass wir
diesen freundlichen austausch
miteinander hatten sie haben gemerkt wir
haben sehr lange zu zweit miteinander
gesprochen das ist ja ein zeichen dafür
dass es viel zu bereden gibt aber auch
dass es sinn macht und dass wir das sehr
kooperativ miteinander tun können hier
treffen wir uns in einer zeit in der
krieg in europa herrscht das ist etwas
was sich wahrscheinlich keiner von uns
hat vorstellen mögen obwohl man die
gefahren noch den letzten jahren immer
wieder hat sehen können der russische
überfälle auf die ukraine geht
unvermindert weiter furchtbare bilder
und die nachrichten über sehr schlimmes
leid erreichen uns aus dem osten unseres
kontinents die alle da geht es uns
beiden nicht anders als vielen bürgern
und bürgern unserer länder hängen vor
den fernsehapparaten schoss die bilder
an und machen uns sorgen um die menschen
die ihr leben verlieren um die familien
die auseinandergerissen werden um die
zerstörung der ukraine stattfinden wir
sind uns beide präsident erdogan und ich
völlig einig in der verurteilung des
gewaltsamen militärischen vorgehens
russlands in der ukraine
und wir sind uns völlig einig dass es so
schnell wie möglich einen
waffenstillstand geben muss denn dass es
jetzt richtig damit nicht weiteres
menschenleben gefährdet wird es muss
sichere korridore geben für zivilisten
dass sie sich aus den gefährdeten orten
unbeschadet heraus beginnen können auch
das muss sofort geschehen aber das
sollten wir uns immer wieder klar machen
mit jedem tag mit jeder bombe entfernt
sich russland mehr aus dem kreis der
weltgemeinschaft die wir miteinander
bilden deswegen unser gemeinsamer klarer
appell an den russischen präsidenten
halten sie inne zu diesem konflikt kann
es nur eine diplomatische lösung geben
und diesem hintergrund sind natürlich
die intensiven gesprächen zwischen der
ukraine und russland sehr wichtig wir
beide haben uns über das ausgetauscht
was wir aus unseren gesprächen wissen
mit präsident selensky aber auch
präsident putin ich habe selber viele
gespräche mit dem russischen präsidenten
und auch gemeinsam mit dem französischen
präsidenten
ich habe mich immer wieder intensiv mit
präsident selensky beraten das ist ganz
wichtig dass wir hier alles dafür tun
dass solche gespräche nicht abreißen
sollen fortgesetzt werden aber wir
müssen dafür sorge tragen dass jetzt
auch bald ergebnisse erzielt werden die
ein wachstumsstillstand ermöglichen
begrüße auch die bemühungen unserer
türkischen verbündeten die zu einer
diplomatischen lösung beitragen wollen
es ist gut dass es auch gespräche
zwischen dem russischen und ukrainischen
außenminister gegeben und hier das hilft
alles hilft was jetzt gespräche möglich
macht und das ist wichtig und
verdienstvoll
wir leisten alle gemeinsam tatkräftig
hilfe für die hunderttausenden die
millionen die auf der flucht sind wir
wissen dass in polen schon über 1,7
millionen flüchtlinge angekommen sind
dass in ländern wie deutschland ist auch
schon weit über 100.000 sind auch in der
türkei sind viele flüchtlinge angekommen
türkische staatsbürger konnten aus der
ukraine herausgebracht werden aber es
sind eben auch ukrainerin ukrainer und
viele drittstaatsangehörige die sich
dort aufhalten da sind wir alle
gemeinsam jetzt mit dieser aufgabe
versehen dafür zu sorgen dass die dinge
dort sich anders entwickeln können
wir wollen im übrigen dafür sorge tragen
dass die ukraine sich selbst verteidigen
kann wir machen das mit finanzieller
hilfe mit humanitärer hilfe mit all dem
was wir auch an waffen hilfe geleistet
haben die türkei aber auch deutschland
und deshalb will ich an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich erwähnen dass die
schließung der bosporus durchfahrt für
kriegsschiffe der kriegsführenden
parteien im rahmen der anwendung der
montreux konvention durch die türkei ein
ganz wichtiger beitrag ist für eine
deeskalation der aktuellen krise dafür
will ich ausdrücklich danken jetzt geht
es darum das wie gesagt ein
waffenstillstand schnell vereinbart wird
und das ist eine möglichkeit gibt aus
diesem krieg heraus zu kommen was wir
uns gemeinsam richtig und wichtig ist es
hier festzuhalten dass die territoriale
integrität und die souveränität der
ukraine außer frage stehen und dass die
verletzung des souveränitätsrechte
ukraine eine außerordentliche verletzung
des europäischen rechts is und des
friedens in europa
natürlich hat das konsequenzen deshalb
ist es wichtig dass wir in der nato und
miteinander zusammenarbeiten
wir haben uns sehr sorgfältig über die
veränderte sicherheitssituation
besprochen ich habe auch darüber
informiert dass deutschland wie auch
andere nato staaten ihre konkrete
präsenz entlang der ostgrenze der nato
verstärken im wald die kommen in der
slowakei was deutschland betrifft mit
dem r police in rumänien auch die türkei
weist du dein entsprechenden beitrag in
dieser situation und wir werden das auch
für die zukunft tun und für uns ist
wichtig dass wir gleichzeitig nicht
überhört haben was wir verstehen müssen
nämlich dass der gewaltsame bruch des
rechts den russland hier vornimmt auch
bedeutet dass wir selber sicher und
stark genug sein müssen deshalb ist es
so wichtig dass wir dafür sorgen dass
unsere verteidigung gut funktioniert sie
wissen dass deutschland sich
entschlossen hat einen zusätzlichen
fonds von 100 milliarden euro aufzulegen
um die bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes zu
stärken und dafür zu sorgen dass wir in
der lage sind die sicherheit zu
garantieren die wir gemeinsam garantiert
essen wollen wir haben uns auch
unterhalten über wirtschaftliche
kooperationen in der tat da ist wie
möglich die gute entwicklung der
wirtschaftlichen beziehung hat der
präsident bereits erläutert aus meiner
sicht geht da auch noch mehr und deshalb
haben wir auch schon konkret vereinbart
dass wir konkrete gesprächsformat
etablieren indem wir diese
weiterentwicklung auch möglich machen
wollen dass es in beiderseitigen
interesse eine wichtige rolle nicht nur
zwischen deutschland und der türkei
sondern auch
zwischen
der europäischen union und der türkei
spielt selbstverständlich die
energiekooperation
sie wissen dass deutschland sich das
ehrgeizige ziel gesetzt hat aus der
nutzung fossiler ressourcen auszusteigen
in einer sehr kurzen frist vom knapp
nicht einmal ganz 25 jahren das bedeutet
das für die stromerzeugung aus
erneuerbaren quellen windkraft auf hoher
see an land und sonne ausbauen werden
unser stromnetz stärken werden dass wir
wasserstoff importieren werden das ist
eine aufgabe bei der wir auch dauerhaft
mit anderen kooperieren
müssen denn wasserstoff kann man
national herstellen aber man braucht
wenn man ein so großes industrieland wie
deutschland es auch importe und da sind
viele die auch bisher mit energie etwas
zu tun hatten auch als importeure
künftig gefragt aus erneuerbaren
ressourcen daher wünschen wir uns auch
gute zusammenarbeit
gleichzeitig brauchen wir natürlich eine
diversifizierung der energieversorgung
des infrastruktur in europa das gas und
kohle versorgung aus anderen quellen
betrifft als russland damit wir nicht in
eine abhängigkeit situation verbleiben
sondern uns stück für stück die
notwendige souveränität für eigene
entscheidung schaffen egal wie sich die
geopolitischen verhältnisse entwickeln
da sind zusammen arbeitsmöglichkeiten
zwischen der türkei und europa möglich
genauso wie zwischen dem afrikanischen
kontinent und europa oder zb durch die
errichtung von lng terminals an den
europäischen küsten die dann auch
weltweite importmöglichkeiten schaffen
passt das betrifft das gilt für die
anderen fossilen ressourcen auch das
muss jetzt schnell geschehen damit wir
schnell diversifizieren langfristig ist
das ziel das sich beschrieben hat da
für uns geht es jetzt darum dass wir als
demokratische westliche staaten eng
zusammenarbeiten unsere kooperation in
der nato ist dafür ja ein wichtiger
grundlage und ich glaube dass in diesen
tagen die transatlantische beziehung
noch einmal neu an großen gewicht
bekommen gewonnen dass wir wissen dass
nordamerika und das westliche europa die
europäische union dass die staaten die
in der nato versammelt sind
einschließlich der türkei hier eng
kooperieren und gemeinsam wissen dass
wir unsere sicherheit verteidigen müssen
und das was uns wichtig ist wenn es um
recht tätigkeit geht zum beispiel
demokratie und menschenrechte und
selbstverständlich bedeutet das auch
dass wir unsere regionalen
fragestellungen vorantreiben müssen dass
wir dort die kooperation verbessern
müssen müssen müssen bin sehr froh über
die gespräche die sie mit dem
israelischen staatspräsidenten herzog
geführt haben oder ganz frisch aktuell
mit dem griechischen regierungschef mit
zu tages das sind gute zeichen für das
was wir weiter entwickeln müssen in
europa und in unserer zusammenarbeit
die eu und die türkei
arbeiten zusammen es gibt dinge die wir
uns für die zukunft vorgenommen haben
dazu gehört gehören die hochrangigen
dialoge wir wollen uns
selbstverständlich auch für die
weiterentwicklung der zollunion
einsetzen und hoffen dass dort bald
greifbare fortschritte verhandelt werden
können wichtig ist auch unsere
unveränderte zusammenarbeit bei der
migration und bei der aufgabe menschen
die flüchtenden schutz zu bieten diese
kooperationsbeziehungen ist wichtig und
gerade aktuell am fall der ukraine sehen
wir ja dass die themen immer wieder neu
auftreten es ist nicht ein für allemal
erledigt sondern solange die welt so
gewalttätig ist wie wir sie kennen wird
es auch so bleiben dass es menschen gibt
die fliehen die sich ein neues zuhause
suchen die sich in sicherheit bringen da
haben wir aus humanitären gründen eine
verpflichtung der wir folgen müssen wir
haben gute bilaterale beziehung und wir
brauchen auch mit den bilateralen
beziehungen
das ist ganz besonders wichtig weil es
ja in deutschland viele bürgerinnen und
bürger gibt die einen türkischen
hintergrund haben weil entweder sie
selbst oder ihre eltern oder großeltern
aus der türkei nach deutschland
eingewandert sind das ist heute ein ganz
lebendiger teil unserer bürgerschaft in
deutschland unsere deutschen
staatsbürgerinnen und staatsbürger mit
diesem hintergrund und ich freue mich
dass wir auch in der bundesregierung und
im bundestag viele türkischstämmige
männer und frauen haben die jetzt ganz
aktiv als bürgerinnen und bürger der
bundesrepublik deutschland als deutsche
die politischen geschicke und es das ist
tatkräftig mit gestalten wir sind wie
gesagt miteinander wirtschaftlich
verbunden auch das gilt für unsere
bilateralen beziehungen und wir wollen
wie wir beide schon ausgeführt haben das
auch weiter verbessern natürlich gibt es
das gehört zu den dingen dazu die gesagt
werden müssen auch
differenzen belastungen unterschiedliche
ansichten die wir haben etwa wenn es um
fragen von menschenrechten und
rechtsstaatlichkeit geht oder die
perspektiven deutscher staatsangehöriger
in der türkei die mit hausarrest
ausweise sperren belegt sind zum
beispiel oder gar sich in haft befinden
hier hat es in letzter zeit ein paar
bewegung gegeben wir hoffen dass es für
viele fälle eine baldige lösung geben
wird
darüber haben wir gesprochen
wir wollen unsere bilateralen
beziehungen nach kräften ausbauen und
die gewaltigen potenziale unserer
zusammenhang voll ausschöpfen
ausschöpfen dafür steht meine regierung
und ich glaube nach dem gespräch dass
wir miteinander geführt haben dafür
stehen wir beide dass wir das
miteinander hinkriegen noch an
staatspräsident herzlichen dank für den
empfang heute wird das gute ausführliche
und wirklich konstruktive gespräch und
ich freue mich sehr ausdrücklich auch
über die weitere zusammenhang unsere
reporterin angelika hellemann hatte olaf
scholz nach ankara begleitet ist dort
jetzt live zugeschaltet angelika außer
deiner sicht war das eintreffen von dem
irgendeine signal der hoffnung aus geht
die forderung nach einem
waffenstillstand ist nun nicht mehr neu
nein diese forderung ist nicht neu dass
hier ganz interessant ist es war klar
dass erdogan in ganz china partner für
die nato für den westen bleibt weil das
erstaunliche war dass olaf scholz immer
betont hat dass putin der aggressor ist
dass es eine waffenruhe geben muss dass
dieser krieg aufs schärfste zu
verurteilen ist dass sich putin mit
jeder weiteren bombe von der
weltgemeinschaft entfernt und von
erdogan kam kein einziger böses wort
über putin im gegenteil er betont weiter
die äquidistanz zwischen
moskau und kiew die anker hier einnehmen
will und hat ganz klar gesagt dass er
sowohl der freund von helsinn lenski
also dem ukrainischen präsidenten als
auch von premier putin dem russischen
bleiben will
tut er das vielleicht auch deshalb um
überhaupt eine vermittlerrolle die ja
schon begonnen hat weiter einnehmen zu
können
ja wahrscheinlich tut er das und er
kauft ja auch weitermachen zum russland
der ukraine liefert er hingegen waffen
es ist alles ein bisschen kompliziert
das problem ist nur es gibt noch keinen
wirklichen vermittler der von beiden
seiten akzeptiert wird und wenn es
wirklich einmal irgendwann
friedensverhandlungen geben wird dann
müssen dort schon also erst mal die
beiden präsidenten zu putin am tisch
sitzen aber es wird dann eher ein
internationales format sein also in
einer neutralen stadt an einem neutralen
land und dann eben mit vielen anderen
ländern mit drumherum am tisch es wird
nicht erdogan alleine derjenige sein der
eine pendeldiplomatie zwischen diesen
beiden ländern acht sondern es zeigt er
tatsächlich dass das nato mitglied
türkei immer auch wieder seinen eigenen
weg geht und scholz hat dann einmal
betont dass die türkei doch sehr wohl
den krieg in der ukraine aus schärfste
verurteilt hätte also er hat sozusagen
erdogan hier haben eigenen palast
eigentlich für seine eigene haltung
belehrt
erdogan traditionell eine schwieriger
partner für deutschland das war schon
unter angela merkel so und auch jetzt
unter olaf scholz
olaf scholz hat in der anschließenden
pressekonferenz ganz klar gesagt dass
man auch differenzen angesprochen habe
was eben menschenrechte angeht und
rechtsstaatlichkeit während erdogan nur
die herzliche atmosphäre betont hat ja
das stimmt das hat olaf scholz aber auch
schon im hintergrund im flieger
angekündigt dass er natürlich trotz
aller probleme und obwohl er halt die ja
den die nato und den westen
zusammenhalten will weil er sozusagen
einigkeit als den schlüssel sieht um
putin dann doch schritte richtung
frieden abzutrotzen sieht will er
trotzdem probleme wie
menschenrechtsverletzungen oder die
beschneidung von freiepresse eben klar
deutlich ansprechen unterm strich fazit
aus deiner sicht angelika hellemann die
türkei ein schwieriger partner die wir
aber jetzt brauchen
die nato und auch der westen braucht die
türkei also es ist ein wichtiger partner
aber ein schwieriger und man wird
einfach mal da sprechen müssen und
dieser furchtbaren krieg zeigt halt dass
man sich eben seine gesprächspartner
nicht immer aussuchen kann angelika
dammann live aus ankara nach dem besuch
von olaf scholz dem antrittsbesuch dem
offiziellen beim türkischen
staatspräsidenten erdogan dank angelika